conditions in many prisons in the
Americas region are deeply worrying
pre-existing structural problems such as
chronic overcrowding and hygienic
conditions coupled with a lack of proper
access to health care have enabled the
rapid spread of covered 19 in many
facilities across the continent yeah
then you heard it the United Nations
says prisons across Latin America are a
breeding ground for the coronavirus we
have heard similar warnings here at
Europe Germany has prevented outbreaks
in its prisons by releasing prisoners up
to a thousand inmates have gone free my
colleague and reporter I mean
Esav has been speaking with prisoners
however who paint a very different
picture of what is going on behind bars
I mean what what do they been telling
essentially that the measures put in
place to protect them by state
governments in Germany are not being
implemented that staff are still coming
in going sometimes not wearing face
masks not keeping their distance from
prisoners getting very close to them
also that prisoners themselves are not
keeping socially distanced that they're
still eating lunch in groups I spoke to
several prisoners at pollutants they
here in Berlin who said this and they're
very concerned I spoke to one prisoner
44 years old Christian F he is part of a
high-risk group so he has diabetes he
has heart problems and a high blood
pressure and he doesn't feel that the
prison is protecting him and he fears
for his life so let's take a look at
what he said okay the mood is relatively
tense many prisoners feel anxious and
insecure about the steps being taken
especially since we don't know what's
coming and important information from
authorities about what we should do is
generally not available when things will
return to normal or rather a new normal
no one knows I talked to the
spokesperson for the Justice Ministry
here in Berlin who contradicted what he
said they said they're implementing all
the measures possible to protect the
prisoners and that
prisoners inside pollutants a prison are
spreading rumors about the question it
makes you wonder who's checking on the
people who are checking on the prisoners
these prison authorities are do you
think they're making a trade off between
prisoners rights and their safety well I
think prisons essentially are a trade
off between rights and safety and I
think what we're seeing globally is that
a global pandemic
makes this even more complicated so yeah
the simple answer is yes
prisons all across Germany have done
things like banned family visits banned
group activities like sports and church
service so essentially prisoners are
living in a kind of isolation that's
usually used to punish bad behavior and
this has taken a heavy toll on them
psychologically I spoke to RIA halbreth
or she's a lawyer and expert in criminal
rights and she said that the trade-off
is a hard one it's very light it's
really really awful for inmates now with
the restrictions especially now that
visits aren't allowed but to be very
clear no one wants to be the one who
brings coronavirus into the prison
because the effect is an outbreak things
would become much worse much more
disastrous not truly obviously something
needs to be done to protect prisoners
and that will of course have drawbacks
advocates are also saying that the
trade-off is necessary but that
prisoners could be urged prisons rather
could be urged to make a more difficult
trade-off and invest more money into
better spaces and better healthcare for
prisoners yeah we'll see if that happens
anytime soon
I mean as always thanks for your
reporting thanks Brent